Thank you so, so much for joining us today.
It's been a great convention so far.
How many of you have been to at least one or other event here this weekend?
Hope you all have been having a great time when we have one more fantastic panel.
Please, give it up for Doki Bird!
So nice to see all you guys.
Oh my gosh, you must be really, really busy right now.
There's so many fun events and so many stuff to buy.
I was talking to a drag owner who spent around $3,000 on a chair.
That's crazy.
That's why I'm calling you up, buddy.
Hey!
Yeah, we're having a great time.
I was roaming around the vendors slash artists.
It was like an hour or two ago.
I didn't even finish it.
Apparently, one of my staff told me there was like around a hundred plus booths that's just selling Doki merch.
And I was like, what?
We already maxed out one credit card.
Oh my God!
And so we got like to put these two of our staff's credit cards to buy my door.
It was crazy.
All business expenses.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I even bought like, there was apparently like this drag room plushie that was not for sale.
And I was like, I want it.
I don't care.
Oh, it's just the staff up from the factory.
I was like, I don't care.
I want it so no other drag room can have it.
I don't care.
Every time.
That's right.
Ah, patient zero.
I'm good at drag room plushie.
Yeah, apparently today, there's gonna be a little Q&A.
So you drag rooms can ask me some questions.
Any questions that you've always wanted to ask me.
It's like a little Vectagon stream here.
I'm super excited to talk to all of you guys.
Woo!
I'm just walking around and getting some questions.
So, I guess, while I get in position, I will ask the first one.
What is the most unexpected piece of work that you found in Wendell?
Oh, in UpKai?
Hmm.
Oh, I, oh, uh, uh, who was it?
Uh, I don't think there's that many boosts today, because, like, I think we only had, like, an hour and a half, and we only wasn't able to get, like, we only got, like, 20 boosts in.
But, out of those 20 boosts, I think the most unexpected one was a bottle opener.
A bottle opener!
And I was like, oh, man, I've never seen that before, you know, like, a VTuber bottle opener?
Uh, think finally I can open my bottles more conveniently.
I was like, yeah, I got that this year, but I think that one was the, uh, most, uh, uh, unexpected merch that I found at UpKai.
I think another unexpected merch that I saw on Twitter was, was the deodorant.
I heard the mid-deodorant got sold right now on the first day.
Yup, yup.
I thought that was, I thought that was really funny.
Uh, but yeah, those are the two of the most unexpected merch I've seen.
All right, who else has got a question?
Yeah, who wants to start with a meeting in there?
Hi!
Hi, Doki!
There you go.
Hi!
Hi, Doki!
Yeah, everyone!
So, I'm going to ask the same question.
Hey, when are we getting renamed to Neskos?
Never.
Also, I like that there's like two minions in that.
How about over here?
Hello.
Hello, hello.
My name is Rune, and I love your new summer costume.
Thank you!
What is your favorite summer activity?
What is my favorite summer activity?
Oh, that's difficult because I hate the ocean.
I actually, okay, I know we all like, oh my gosh, the beach episode.
But I actually really hate the beach.
Because, you know, like, sand gets into everywhere and it's disgusting.
And also, like, I don't like the ocean because I always see it as, like, the nature's toilet.
Because, you know, the fish are there and then the other types of sea animals are there.
And, you know, where do they go?
And they need to use the bathroom.
In the ocean.
And then we go in the ocean and we, you know, open our mouths.
I haven't been to the beach for a while.
But, like, if I had to pick my favorite summer activity at the beach, it would be like, I don't know.
I guess, like, eating watermelon or ice cream, like, that seems like the most least harmful thing you can do on the beach.
And definitely on, like, a patio or something, so I'm gonna have to touch the grass.
That's my favorite each activity.
Alright, I have one right up here.
Hello, Doki.
My name is Jimbo.
So, I'm a fellow Apex player as well.
So, I just reached out to the end of the season.
Anyway, I'm not that good at trash talking.
So, is there any advice for you, as a new trash talker, to learn trash talking in Apex Alton?
Especially when I'm still looking at you.
It's really challenging anyone to help me tossing.
Like, I don't know.
It's really difficult to be toxic these days because, like, you can get recorded and then they'll mute your account.
I remember, like, I saw, like, a tweet from someone who was trying to trash talk in Overwatch.
And all they said was, like, they said, all they said was, like, swap off this character.
You're bad at it.
And then their account got muted.
It took two months.
So, I was like, honest.
That's why I trash talk to you guys about people.
Because, like, what are they gonna do?
Clip me?
And they're trying to ban me off on my street?
We can't do that.
Like...
But...
And you really want to test the wires.
Like, test to see if we respond.
Who's gonna look through the reports or anything.
Um...
Usually...
Okay, I...
I...
Yes, I don't...
I'm...
I'm only toxic internally in my head to people.
But...
I would be like...
I would be like, do you have ads?
Like...
I think...
Oh...
Or, like, uninst...
No, you should just uninstall, like...
Like...
That's like the easiest thing to say, to be like, Oh, man.
You might as well uninstall.
It's like...
This game's not for you.
But, like, if you really want to be, like...
You can be passive-aggressive and your count won't be bad.
Because when you look through the course, you'll be like, oh, look, he's just trying to be encouraging.
So this is something that I learned from one of my friends, Surefour, because he would do this the whole time to me.
He was like, good job, guys, and then he would give a smile.
You guys are doing that to me.
And then I'm like, hey, everybody, keep yourself safe.
Stop, stop, stop.
Or like, you should really keep yourself safe.
So I'm like, yeah, yeah, we can't batten you for that.
I'm like, oh, you won't have to be safe.
That's nice, but then when you think about it, what are the initials of keep yourself safe?
And I'm afraid it's not been bad for me for saying stuff like this.
Like, those are like easy tips to get past the report system.
Yeah.
That was your part.
I know.
Hi, Dougie.
Hey.
My name is Inu.
I wanted to say a quick question.
In a much more purple age, you used my art for one of your birthdays.
And at the last time, VTuber linked my stuff in their screen.
So from the bottom of my heart, thank you for that.
My main question was, I'll have like a Marvel rival stream at like 3 AM.
And I know that you always have your usual Doki amount of energy.
So what is your usual like routine or mental gymnastics that keep you from just passing out mid-string while trying to pop a little hole?
Okay, like for me when it comes to like competitive games, I actually like, my entire body runs off of the pure adrenaline of competitiveness.
That's why like, for me, I always tell people I cannot do a 24 hour stream.
Like, I remember trying to do a 24 hour stream a long, long time ago.
Like before they, during like retro era Doki.
And then like, cause it was like a cherry to go back then during retro Doki era.
And, um, I mean, I gave up after 12 hours cause I was like, I can't guys.
Like, I don't have the energy for this.
But if I had to, if I could, if I could just play competitive stuff.
Obviously you guys know I've done like a 16 hour, like Marvel Rivals just ranked, right?
And that was because it was all just pure adrenaline of playing ranked.
Um, because I just like to see the numbers go up.
Like, or I'm due to it.
It's one or the other.
You know, he was like, you can't end on a loss.
And you can't end on a, you can't break your win streak, you know?
Um, but, uh, basically for me, it's just, after stream, I'm like, I don't exist as a person.
I'm like, I'm running on like power save mode.
So like, sometimes after stream, I just be like, I'm like, I'm not like a sentient being when the stream's over.
Like, I literally just like, it's like recharged, like blanked out, disassociated on my bed.
And I'm like, okay, I'll, I'll get up after I become a person.
That's basically how I, I don't think that's healthy, to be fair.
That's not healthy.
And so, so learn from me, yeah, that's not that healthy.
But, um, but for me, if I use too much energy during the stream, that's basically, I just like, recharge, I take like one to two hours of just not existing to recharge myself.
Hi, Doki, it's, uh, Osnia again.
I wanted to ask a question that I didn't have time to ask during the free.
Um, so you said that you, uh, haven't gone through all of the Artist Alley.
Uh, have you had time to go through your bio?
I'll just say, I'll just say, cause I know like, during, when I was at Fatimae, they also had something similar.
They had like an R18 Artist Alley there.
I just said my staff member, like, hi!
I mean like, alright, staff member, you, you go explore the R18 section and just let me know if there's any Doki merch.
But like, I, I, I, I have not run through like a bio market.
I know there's Doki stuff in there.
But I, I don't know if today there's, there's a bio market today.
But, if there is, my staff member will, will walk through it.
I won't be there.
I, I know there's things that my eyes shouldn't be seeing.
We have a, it's pretty very important update over here.
Uh, hi Doki.
Uh, I'm Hadoon.
And, uh, a piece of, uh, this content that just always brings a spark to my life.
Uh, we get, uh, Off Tye exclusive, uh, dad update.
I don't know what he's doing!
Okay, okay.
Lately, he's been an asshole.
I have no idea why.
He's actually been a terrorizer.
So if another dog has interest in him, they go up to him, and he baits them too.
Like, you know, he lets them come close, but then when they get close to him, he'd just be like...
And then he scares them away, and I'm like, what the fuck are you doing?
I'm like, why are you baiting them?
He just told them to get off early on.
Why are you making them think that you guys are best friends?
And then proceeds to harass them.
Also, he really, really hates children.
He sees them as, like, a dog that's bigger than him.
Because he hates dogs that are taller than him.
Which is the majority of the dogs.
Look at these, like, goddamn weird dogs.
So, yesterday, I was trying to take him back from a walk.
And then there was a bunch of kids just running from the hallway, and he didn't like that.
He was like, what are you doing?
I was like, stop running in the halls!
How dare you!
Like, he just doesn't, I don't know, he just doesn't like children.
He just sees them as, like, bigger dogs.
And he feels frightened by it.
So, I've been a big fan since your debut.
I've really liked your music.
And I wanted to know if you had any new music coming out.
Oh!
I mean, there is a concert next month.
That's all I can say.
There is a concert next month.
So, maybe...
Class of class.
Edna's working right here.
Hey, Debbie.
Hello!
A long time ago, in the before times, I remember when you streamed after getting with the kids removed.
And I'm wondering if you have any recollection of that, or if you ever listened back to your own recordings.
Technically, okay, so I remember I did like a, what was it called, a Twitter Space.
Technically, I wasn't allowed to do a Twitter Space.
Technically, I wasn't allowed to do a Twitter Space back then.
But I think it's because, like, obviously I had my wisdom teeth removed, so I didn't...
Like, I didn't remember or cared about that.
But I think, like... I think, like...
Um... I just remembered I didn't get, like, reprimanded for it.
Because, like, I don't know, maybe they just didn't know I did do a Twitter Space back then.
Uh...
But, uh...
Honestly, I don't remember what I said during that.
I just remembered, I was like, oh shit, wait, I'm not supposed to do a Twitter Space after, like, the post-wism teeth surgery.
Um...
But I have no idea what I said during that stream.
It's, like, lost archives.
Uh, hey, Doki.
It's good seeing you.
Uh, before I get to my question, I just want to say congratulations on the sex with me last year.
I know you're a huge fan of Dynasty Warriors, the series, and the whole Romantic Three Kingdom though, right?
Yeah.
I have a question with that is, out of all the dialogue and lines in the game, do you think of one that you can find that you can say to men about how much you like her?
Do you have a question?
Is that all the lines...
I mean, I can't.
Um, the only thing I can remember, if you want me to quote a line from Dynasty Warriors, is, Do not pursue nooboo.
That'll be my line.
Do not pursue nooboo.
Hello.
How are you doing?
I'm doing great.
So, as one of the founding members of TSB, who is the best girl out of Regis and Axel?
Who is the best bro?
I feel like I'd be the best bro.
I feel like I'm the most bro out of all the bro-tubers out there.
I'm an OG bro-tuber.
I remember when we asked that question for Axel, he was like, hell no.
He wouldn't even do it.
Like, that's fucked up.
That's not bro-behavior.
Wait, so if you're the bro...
Like, you just let your bro die like that?
No one will know.
Like, only you and your bro will know.
He'll die like that.
Hi, Doki.
Hey!
I'm Virgil.
Uh...
Normal Phantom Deep fan.
Very normal.
And, uh...
What are the odds that you would play Silent Hill F?
If you meant that you would- No.
I think that I'll chill.
I would say...
I would- I did say that I'll only play Silent Hill F if I ever hit a million subscribers.
That is like my only thing that I'll only do Silent Hill F.
I played Silent Hill Remastered or two, and that shit was actually- Like, I was so scared.
Like, I could only play two hours mass every playthrough.
So it was- it was- it was that bad.
Like, if I had a heart monitor, my heart- I think you would have to call a doctor if you can- You know, like, if you saw, like, where my heartbeat was going.
Like, people would be like- Wait, that's not- I don't think- Wait a minute.
I think we actually have to call the- The hospital for hair.
Um, but I'll only do it if I ever hit a million subscribers.
Like, I am not- I'm not willingly doing that.
Or I can bribe.
I'll do anything for money.
How much?
Woo!
Five dollars!
Thank you!
Hey, Dougie.
Hello!
I'm gonna say, uh, four weeks earlier.
And, uh, what's your favorite Project Sekai group?
Do you need one more jump, Vivid Bad Squad, Wonderland, or Night Court?
Oh, I think- Oh, I love- I think Wonderland's pretty cute.
To be fair, I don't know that much about Project Sekai.
I remember Wonderland because you're based off of that amusement park, and I thought they were all so cute.
But, um, I'm not a rhythm gamer, so, like, obviously I have a huge lack of, uh, knowledge of rhythm games.
It's because I lack rhythm, so I don't, you know, I don't wanna, like, I don't like playing- I personally don't like playing games I'm bad at.
That's why you don't have to see me play Valor.
Because I'm bad at tactical shootings.
Yeah!
What are you doing?
Uh, hi, my name is Aris.
I've been a long time with that.
Well, as a- One thing I always like is when you do the, uh, meadow stream.
Which, is that something you never revisit again?
Oh, absolutely.
I've been wanting to do that for, like, the longest time.
Obviously, like, it takes a lot of prep time to do these things.
So, and, like, I've been so busy.
So, I don't have time to, like, do I actually, like, cook for myself?
Or, like, you know, prepare, like, these types of streams?
Because, like I said, it takes a lot of amount of prep.
Also, I don't have a rice cooker.
I've been- What?!
What?!
I haven't bought a rice cooker.
So, that's, like, the number one thing I need to do.
But...
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm fine.
I know.
I can't- I- I'm disgraced all Asians.
I can't use a pot, by the way.
I can't.
My ancestors will leave me in all these things to hell.
They're waiting on me through the gates.
Oh, that's a lot of questions.
I can't.
Hey, yo.
This is your boy, Jeff.
Thank you.
I'm going to check.
Is that a midwife here?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah!
It's like, oh wait, it's him again!
Yeah, I'm sure.
My boy, Walter.
It's an artist.
So, my question is, whenever you're interacting with Minton, you hang out in person.
What's the most pet peevee thing that you do to each other?
What's the most pet peevee thing we do to each other in real life?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, man.
I'm trying to- I just know, like, every time- Like, sometimes I do things to reach Peter.
I'm just like, why are you like this?
I can't, like, name an instance, because I like rage-painting her, because it's like, I just like seeing reactions of people, and she's just like, like, why are you like this?
Um, but yeah, that's basically, like, it's just me rage-painting her.
Okay.
Hello.
My name is Marcus.
Alright.
My question for you is, um, for this year's scenario character poll, what did you vote for and why?
Okay.
I- Perfect.
I know, like, I know there's gonna be some haters out there, but I don't care.
But obviously, I will vote for my first- my- my Kami Oshii, Sinomura, because, like, I don't care if he has won for, like, five plus years in a row.
I don't care.
This is the greed they talk about in the Bible.
He deserves to be number one.
And if you're mad that he's always number one, then maybe you should have supported your Oshii better.
I don't care.
I voted for Sinomura.
He shall be king for other- for years, for generations, until the universe dies.
I don't fucking care.
Oh, my favorite part is that Kampampurak almost beat- I don't know if he beats Sinomura, but he was, like, first or second place or some shit at the character polls, but then- but then they kept drawing him, like, his ass up, because- like, you know, showing his butt,
and then, like, I remember seeing, like, a Sinomura fast, and they're like, Sni!
I hear Sni!
Um, hi, uh, in all your years as a VTuber, what is, like, your favorite fan interaction or moment that has happened to you?
My favorite fan interactions, oh my gosh.
Oh!
I think my favorite- I think it has to be, like, the very first time I've ever seen, like, a cosplayer doing a Me and Green with me, because it's, like, like, someone that's cosplaying me, because it's, like, you know, such a unique experience to be like,
wait, that's me!
Oh my god, hi, don't you?
But I think that's, like, the most fun part for me when I see, like, you know, obviously, like, cosplaying, as you need, might take a lot of- especially during the summer, if you're trying to cosplay, like, I'm hungry.
Um, skin suit, I didn't think this through, because I forgot wearing leather jackets is, like, really, really hot, and there's a lot of people at conventions, so it means it gets even hotter.
So, I was like, I did think this through, I was like, oh, man, this is gonna be easy to cosplay, and then I realized, oh, man, you're in a sauna right now wearing my cosplay.
Hi.
Hello.
My question is, you have some pretty iconic expressions that you've made before.
I was wondering if you kind of, like, test out your rhythm before streams, or if they happen more sporadically?
Oh, they just happen.
Me testing things before streams?
And then they get on my PC and just be like, start streaming.
And there have been too many instances where, you know, people be like, Cookie, did you not test your game before the stream?
And I'd be like, uh...
Like, what do you think as I boot up my super, waiting for a game to tap in leather?
Hey, thank you.
Hey!
Say you drank a bit too much the night before, and you need to end.
What would, uh, your tactics be?
Oh, my God.
I'm like, too much.
And I'm like, boy, am I like, hum-over?
So, that, did you know that I am primary for gamers?
Oh, my God.
Get back.
Chug down some caffeine and be like, start streaming.
If I get a heart attack on stream, I get a heart attack.
I love it, but it is what it is.
Yes.
Hello, Mario.
I don't know if this is a number of characters, but does this guy come for him?
Is this, is it a favorite, but he actually has that kind of thing?
Question.
Hi, Donkey.
Hey.
My question is, what's the favorite rabbit hole you've ever gone down, ever in a row?
Recently.
Oh, that's different though.
Because, like, okay.
Okay, so, I'll confess this as off guy.
But, like, okay, so, I've never watched, uh, what's that show called?
Arcane?
I've never watched Arcane.
I have so many friends begging me to watch Arcane.
But the one thing that's stopping me from watching Arcane is that league.
And that's too scary.
I'm scared.
I don't want to get addicted to league.
I've never played league before.
And I don't want Arcane to be the one that, like, gets me into league.
Because I'm afraid of league.
I'm in a row.
I've seen what it's done to people.
And I'm scared.
So, but, like, one of my friends has been begging me to watch League of Legends Arcane for so long.
And they were like, no, you have to.
It's so good.
And I was like, I was like, I can't.
I can't go.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I've seen what league can do to people.
But, like, I got curious.
So, I, look, you know, like, when you get curious about a show or a book that you, or, like, a game that you've never watched, and then you dive into, like, the fandom Wikipedia page, and then, like, two hours later, you're jumping between articles because you're,
like, wondering, oh, okay, so what's happening next?
Like, oh, wait, that's interesting.
What's this?
So, I've done that several times for different fandoms.
Like, I've done it for, like, Star Wars because, like, I got curious.
Because I've never actually watched Star Wars.
I've only watched three Star Wars movies in my whole entire life.
And it was, like, the first, very first Star Wars movie.
And the very first Star Wars movie in the, what's that one it's called?
The one with Rey, and the first one from that.
And then the first one from, um, god, what was it called?
I'm sorry, Star Wars, but it's, like, the trickles.
So, I've always watched the first movie out of all these installments.
But, like, I got really curious about the lore and everything.
So, I just, like, read the art, Wikipedia pages, and then I could dive into it.
So, I did that for Arkane.
And then, like, there's, like, two characters in Arkane.
What are their names?
Um, it's, like, the Russian guy in the Latinx show, right?
That's pretty good.
And I was like, wait, are they, you know, happy Pride Month?
I was like, what are they?
I was like, wait, are they?
And then my friend was like, no one else.
They're just really, really good friends.
And then, like, I was like, really good roommate.
And then my friend was like, okay, maybe.
So, that was like the thing.
I was like, oh, so you could say that you're good roommates, right?
And he was like, yeah, you could say that.
And he was like, really good roommates.
So that's like the rabbit hole I've recently been into.
Hi, Doki.
Devin here.
Very nice to be here.
Hello.
My question is a bit of a math refresher.
I'm just wondering, can you tell me what is the largest hole number?
Okay, honestly, I know what it is now.
And I thought it was two.
If you remember that thought, I was like, oh, is it two?
But obviously, I didn't even believe in myself because I almost failed math.
So I was like, and it's like first grade.
Do you know how?
It's so many years ago since first grade.
When will I ever have to do anything where I have to know what a whole number is?
Anyway, but yes, I know it's two.
The next greatest number is two.
Thank you.
Okay.
May you come up?
Aw.
It's Japanese.
The question is, I have a sister who plays Marvel Rivals on the regular.
What advice should I give to her to get better at the game?
Is she?
Okay.
What role does she play?
Um, I think last time I saw her was support?
I don't know.
She also played Scarlet Witch.
She plays Scarlet Witch and Rocket.
Oh my god.
Alright, my first advice is that she knows she has hands, right?
Okay.
So, oh my god.
How can I give advice for Scarlet Witch?
Like, that's... I didn't rock it.
Um, okay.
Um, well, if she wants to get better as either of those characters, since you don't need hands to play either of them, it's literally all about positioning and making sure, like, you're, you know, like, where you're standing.
And, like, when to disengage and when to engage.
Because Rocket, you know, he can fucking go everywhere.
Like, as long as, like, if you have less than three deaths, actually, no, maybe not.
I would say, like, four deaths are less on support, and you're doing a great job.
If you don't, if you have more than four deaths as Rocket, then you're doing something wrong.
Because Rocket can, like, jump everywhere.
You can dash everywhere.
You can climb every wall.
So, you have more than four deaths on Rocket, and you're losing, then it's because you're positioning such ass.
That's all I can say.
Okay, my question is, out of all the streams we've done, which one is your favorite?
Oh, oh, that's, I've done so many streams.
That's really, like, even on this channel alone, on, like, my current channel.
I've done, like, uh, like, oh my gosh, how many, how many videos do I have?
I'm trying to check my channel right now.
I have 774 videos on this current channel alone.
Oh, it's, oh, that's such a hard question.
I think, currently, so far, um, on my current channel, I think my favorite stream so far is either, uh, the, uh, either WrestleTuber.
Yeah!
Woooo!
Or, hardcore Minecraft.
The ending was pure cinema for that.
And my third choice would be the safe, the first stage and slime that we ever done.
Woooo!
Very good memories, very, great experience, um, met a lot of amazing people and, um, uh, Uh, yeah, honestly, those three tunes are my favorite so far for the Krayt channel.
Play more seconds!
Hey, Doki.
Hey!
My name is Ravery, and here's a question for you.
So, for any streamer slash YouTuber, what is the most difficult thing to do when they're getting started on YouTube or Twitch, and how do they overcome it by your experience?
Oh, okay, that's a good question.
I've been asked this a lot, too.
But, basically, obviously, I think the hardest part is just getting an audience.
That's the hardest part, because, you know, a lot of people start streaming, and then they're like, how do I get people to watch me?
Um, I highly suggest just, like, networking and getting to know other people in the community if you're starting out, especially because, like, um, you can, like, you can, like, collab with each other and, like, build off an audience through, like, your shared community.
Um, and, like, you know, getting to know other people.
Like, a lot of viewers, I know, like, you guys might love to watch interactions between other YouTubers and, like, the stuff that people go through, and the relationship between other YouTubers as well.
So, like, that's a great way to get started.
Um, another way is that, um, taking back...
Um, I would highly suggest, because I know my channel is on YouTube, but I highly suggest for any, like, English-speaking VTuber or streamer to get started on Twitch, because Twitch is much more, um, much more friendly in terms of discovery.
Uh, because there's, like, you know, the discovery tab and stuff like that, and reading is a lot more straightforward, too, on Twitch.
Um, I'm on YouTube because, like, I like the platform a lot more because of the VOD system, and because I already have an established fan base, so I can't be on YouTube, because a lot of my viewers came from YouTube and just watching YouTube per VTubers in general.
But, um, I think if you're, like, an NA VTuber or, like, someone that streams in English, Twitch is, like, the best way to start, and then you basically put all your short content, you know, you'll use the shorts algorithm, and then make, like, the VODs videos and stuff and all that on your YouTube channel,
because shorts is a great way to increase discoverability, and YouTube loves the shorts algorithm, so even if, like, you're, like, a small timer, and you, like, manage to, like, have, like, one viral clip from just abusing shorts, like, it can help a lot,
basically, because YouTube will push you more.
I don't know, like, if you ever scroll through the shorts feed on YouTube, sometimes you can get, like, random, like, you know, videos with, like, not a lot of comments, not a lot of views, because YouTube loves pushing short content out to people.
But, yeah, that's my advice to you guys.
Hey, Loki!
Hey!
So, my question is a bit of a hypothetical.
If you just got stranded on an island, how do you think you would survive?
I would be impressed if I lived past the second day.
It's like, okay, I don't know if you guys know this, but, like, my career revolves around me staying inside.
So I don't really, I don't really touch grass very often.
I, I, like, I complain when my internet is even, like, like, if it's, like, ten seconds lower, I complain, because I cannot live without buying an internet.
I've been a city girl for, like, a hundred percent of my life.
Even if you take me to a rural area, I'd be surprised I would live past two, like, a week in a rural area, because I don't know if I could.
Like, I feel like I will walk, I will walk into the wild, and then you'll never see me again.
Like, I don't know.
I have too many bad experiences of being outside.
I don't know if I am, if I can survive outside.
Hey, darling.
Hello!
Hello.
Thank you.
Very good.
I wanted to thank you and curse you real quick for editing me in Tekken.
Yeah, I got to make stuff, like, six times last night by a gym playing like that.
I don't know if she's meta now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I heard that, like, Saikoto went from, like, bronze to, like, master in, like, a couple of days, which is crazy.
I'm genuinely...
like, ladders are killing people right now.
So...
My question is, um, you know, I've been trying to get other people, you know, spread the hatred, and get more people into Tekken.
Was there ever a moment when you were learning it, like, where it kind of clicked, and it became fun, or it wasn't just, like, a significant emotional moment the whole time?
Blanking.
Any grappling characters is what, like, finally clicked for me, because, like, I said this before on stream, but, like, I feel like grapplers are, like, the best rage-baiting type of character.
And then, like, when you rage-bait someone successfully, that's, like, what gives me the most energy.
Because you know they're so angry.
And then, obviously, everyone knows that I'm, like, infamous for, like, a one-and-done.
Like, I never rematch, because I was like, why?
Because I know how mad the other person will get if I just don't give them a rematch.
And then they'll never fight me again for that rematch, too.
But that gives me the most energy.
Just knowing how angry the other person gets because of who I play, and me just leaving the match after one game.
I don't give her...
Eh?
I have a simple one.
What's your favorite cheese?
It's my favorite.
Three cheese.
I love three cheese.
Yes!
Good question.
Very good question.
Little Kate.
Eh?
I don't know if you remember me from the...
Oh, you're one of the people that got the stand.
Yeah.
It was great to see you just come in on us.
We're mid-auction.
Yeah, and I, like, encouraged you to be hired.
Yeah, that was really great.
I want to go back to the Tekken topic.
There's a new wrestler coming.
Honestly, I think, like, whenever I ever get back into, like, a fighting game, it has to be, like, a tournament style.
I don't know if I can...
Because...
Because I remember...
I played...
Oh, man, what's that game?
The 2XKO game for me?
Because it was, like, you know, it was right after, like, it was, like, fighting craze, and everybody was, like, hanging up 2XKO.
So I was just like, alright, I'm gonna try.
And then...
I just get my ass beat by you, Dragon.
Trying to play 2XKO with the dragons.
I think that if I ever go back into, like, Tekken or Street Fighter, it definitely has to be a tournament setting.
Because then, like, you know, at least I can, like...
At least I know that I'm playing against other people that are, like, my level.
You know, that are not, like, out there to just beat my ass.
And so...
That's, like, the only time I'll ever come back, really.
Oh, hi, Doggy!
Hello!
Hi!
Since you've become a YouTuber, I know you've been able to travel a lot, go to, like, Japan and other places.
I was just curious if you could travel to anywhere in the world, where would you want to travel to?
Where would I...
Well, I'm...
Okay, truth be told, I'm so Japano.
Like...
And you're like, How could you get tired of listening to Japan...
Okay, guys, when you have to go to Japan, like, so often for, like, business trips and stuff like that, you can actually get so tired of traveling that...
Because, like, for me, I also have to travel, like...
Because, like, from Canada to Japan, it's, like, what, like, a 12-hour flight each time, too.
And that is so exhausting.
And, um, but, uh, for me, if I have to say that I want to travel somewhere right now, I would definitely be to, like, Hong Kong, because, like, for me, I do...
I haven't been back to Hong Kong in a long time, and I do miss the food there, and...
and shopping there, as well.
So I would say...
I would say Hong Kong, yeah.
I really want to go to, like, Ocean Park to see the pandas, because I want to see, like...
I want to see those, like, fat little shits and...
Boh-ho-ho-ho-ho.
Oh, hey, Orca.
Hi, Orca.
Hi.
Yeah?
My question, I
want to ask you a question.
Definitely the hair.
I love the hair style.
I love the hair.
It's my favorite part, for sure.
Also, I realized why you guys put the water balloons, because I saw some comments about the water balloons.
I now know why men would like, would like, why.
I never saw the preview of that months ago.
Hi, Doki.
It's Stick the Figure.
I know it's been a long time, but I was wondering if you'd ever consider doing a wild animal racing tournament again?
Because you definitely should do it with the giraffe last time, but you never still play.
Alright, if we ever get a rematch, it won't be for wild animal racing.
It'll be on the Sonic racing game.
The season passed, and apparently not only can you play as Steve from Minecraft, but you can also play as a SpongeBob too.
It's
$50.
It's $50.
Ooh, question time.
Hi, Doki.
Hey.
My name is Morty, and I've been loving the inspirational out-of-bring screens recently.
Inspirational?
That's such a praise.
And I wanted to ask if there are any other game types physically you want to get into.
But first, before you answer that, I also wanted to ask your opinion on this...
Grrrr.
Oh my god.
Who was your actual question?
That actresses are locked in.
Wait, wait, what was the question again?
I actually forgot.
There's a new type of game you want to get into.
Oh, a new type of game you want to get into.
Um...
I feel like I've played a lot of different game genres over the years of streaming.
So, that's a hard question.
Because I played...
I played everything.
But the one thing I refuse to play on stream...
is JRPG.
Like, nothing can convince me to play JRPG.
Because first off, that requires me to read.
That's already a very difficult hurdle to get through.
But...
I actually don't know.
I feel like I've played a lot of games.
Like, different genres.
I've done, like, roguelikes.
I've done, like, FPS, TTS.
I've done, like, um...
RTS games.
I've done, um...
That's, like, four genres I just named out.
But I know I did more.
I know I did more than four!
Um...
But honestly, I don't know.
Because...
I've done, like, so many games I've always wanted to play.
I did.
Maybe, like...
Mmm...
I would like to do more, like, Dungeons & Dragons type stuff.
Because I've done it, like, once.
I like how the guys are like, YES!
DUNGEONS & DRAGONS!
Yay!
I've done it once.
It was, like...
A long time ago.
Um, I was like...
Who was it?
It was, like...
I don't know, like, sure who was in it.
As well as, um...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
And...
It was so long ago.
I'm trying to, like, remember who was in it.
Um...
But I would love to do it with other YouTubers, too.
Like, D&D.
That was a good experience.
I'd love to do it again.
We have time for one last question.
Oh, last question!
Hi, Ducky.
I'm named Starlord in Marvel Rivals.
And I always like to play 80s music when I play.
Especially in the Japanese city club.
When you play Marvel Rivals, what music do you like to play?
When I'm playing Marvel Rivals?
Oh, for real?
I don't play music when I'm doing competitive.
Because I'm so locked in that my mind is tuned out when it comes to music in general.
But I have such a weird taste of music because I like everything in general.
I think if you look at my channel, you'll see...
And actually, some people might not notice, but I do have like a playlist that I've made for like...
That was made like years ago.
And sometimes I add songs to it, but...
If you look at my channel, there's like a playlist channel there that I used to play when I streamed back in the Park Bikes era.
And that usually shows like all the primary songs that I used to listen to.
Like with my stream and stuff, but...
Usually when I play piano, I don't listen to music because like...
I don't notice music playing because I'm just so locked in.
I guess that was the last question, right?
Did you see me again, you did?
Yes.
Yeah.
Also, if you guys have anyoba guests...